- [Narrator] For a few weeks
between the wet and dry seasons,
this seemingly ordinary
looking river bursts
to life with color.
(water splashing)
(upbeat music)
Caño Cristales is located
in Meta, Colombia.
When the conditions are just right,
an endemic aquatic plant species
that lives in the riverbed blooms,
creating a brilliant show of red color,
often with hints of yellow,
orange, green, and blue.
Because of this, locals refer to the river
as the liquid rainbow, or
the River of Five Colors.
Before 2009, the Caño
Cristales was closed off
to the public due to guerrilla activity
in the surrounding region.
Today, the river can be reached
by horseback or by foot,
and is accessible under the
guidance of local tour guides.
Although this phenomenon only
happens for a short period
of time each year, this living rainbow
leaves a lasting impression.
(upbeat music)